when a queen meets a duchess megan
marketLine prince harry attended the UK
premiere of The Lion King over the
weekend where they met Beyonce and jay-z
and we've got all the details on
everything they talked about including
yes Beyonce Colleen Megan quote my
princess
but Beyonce wasn't the only one
starstruck he had learned Megan was
actually nervous before meeting her at
the premiere the two bonded over their
babies with Beyonce commenting on baby
Archie calling him so beautiful then
Megan starts talking to them about their
twins roomie and Sir Carter
Carrie then also joins the trio and the
baby tuck continued
[Music]
JZ even offered the royal couple a
little parenting advice saying quote the
best advice I can give you always find
time for yourself
my head and my heart are literally
exploding over this at one point Beyonce
also tells the couple the twins couldn't
make the trip but that quote they would
have loved to have been here the rest of
the Lion King cast was happy to be there
sharing their excitement about hanging
with Megan and Harry there's a lot of
protocol makes me think I don't have
enough protocol I don't know who what
you need to what it takes to create
protocol but I'm gonna look into
creating more protocol I feel like I
should be more nervous but I've been
I've been practicing I mean practicing
my protocol I've been practicing so I'm
ready to go I'm ready together they're
gonna feel like I've been doing this for
a million years
and I'm looking forward to seeing Megan
seeing the American royal yeah I'm very
excited I had never even thought about
beating them or thought I would have an
opportunity to and they seemed very cool
so I'm excited actually at Megan Merkel
and I went to the same College we both
went to Northwestern we were all theater
majors at Northwestern and I think she
was a freshman when I was a senior so
I'm gonna see which often teachers she
had and we can compare notes
alright guys what did you love most
about seeing Beyonce and The Lion King
cast meeting Megan let me know and for
all the latest on the Royals Beyonce and
your other favorite celebs keep it
locked to all things et until next time
I'm Katie Krauss and bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]